yo I am super pumped to be back right
now you know what it's been about a
couple weeks since I've made any videos
here for our YouTube channel VHS com and
I am just pumped to be here to continue
our series on how to play chess openings
and we're going to continue with our
subject of the open sicilians
in case you forgotten this is
international master daniel wrench and
hopefully that voice is ringing loud
enough in your ears that you can't even
get it out of your head at night and
it's driving you to insanity or a demon
membership on chest comm haha very funny
right anyway let's rock and roll here
we're going to flip the board as we move
into our discussions we're going to
start with the move order to Knight to
c6 and after d4 take stakes as you can
see from the title of this video we are
here today to discuss the time manav and
the cons sicilians we've grouped them
into the same video because the
structure the pawn structure is the same
for the majority of players probably
even up to about 1800 tournament play
ratings understanding positions based on
the pawn structure and ideas is even
more important than understanding the
theoretical best considered theoretical
moves by let's say the top players in
the world so we're going to group these
two openings as we did with the dragon
accelerate dragon under the same video
here so the the thing about the poulsen
systems as I call them the pulse and
sicilians they even referred to I
believe it's the Pelican Sicilians some
time ago that being the most popular to
being the time on up in the con is that
both involve this move east six and
whenever you combine pushing the e pawn
with the obvious advancement of the C
pawn given that you're playing it open
Sicilian correct you're inherently
taking a risk via the weakening of your
dark squares and you will notice that
though it is not that simple and that
would be an oversimplification of what's
really going on here in these openings
you will notice that when white is
successful certain things tend to happen
and those things might be that blacks
dark squares are exposed or weakened or
neglected in some way by black in many
cases of course black is is doing what
he does in almost every Sicilian which
is trying to play for a six trying to
develop a minority attack on the Queen
side trying to use the space and open
lines that he's been given to do so
obviously the C file being involved in
that hopefully eventually with rook
and black would like to create
counterplay on the queenside
light as we've said he does in just
about every Sicilian so after the movie
six and the move Knight to c3 is played
typically the move Queen to c7 is played
here though a six can also be played and
transpose into a time on off in some
cases a six allows the move order where
white may consider capturing on c6 here
as capturing with the D pawn would would
not lead to a favourable position for
for black ruining his castle but we're
not going to talk too much about that
theory here instead we're going to go
with Queen to c7 and simply point out
that a move like 9 to b5 gaining a tempo
on the Queen can quickly backfire
because without immediate access into
blacks dark squares White's not
achieving very much with that move and
of course as we know from every Sicilian
black is going to play a 6 next and kick
this pony back to his rightful place and
in doing so he'll have gained back his
lost time with the Queen perhaps you
could argue even gaining more important
time as it helps him to quickly play the
move b5
so after Queen to c7 the most commonly
played move order nowadays is Bishop to
e3 and after a six we have officially
reached a timeout of Sicilian now as we
have done in all of the videos here on
particular subjects where we're going to
focus on the key points and try to
highlight for you some of the most
important principles and fundamental
ideas because obviously we cannot
discuss all the theories so what I'd
like to do is go over a couple of the
main lines try to give you a summary
here of what the most popular approaches
for white and obviously summarize
black's ideas along the way after the
move a6 the most common move order these
days is actually the move Queen to d2
which during the beginning part of the
of the 21st century was wasn't for many
players considered a mistake and move
order after Knight f6 castles long
Bishop to b4 it seems as though this pin
here combined with the pressure and
threat of Knight takes e4 was too much
for white to deal with after f3 and d5 a
simple capture would allow black a big
advantage immediately destroying White's
Queen side making him regret counseling
long and in many cases it looks like you
know let's say after some sort of simple
move anything like this destroying
destroying black sub black so it's hard
to store
queenside is going to leave leave black
with a very strong attack obviously
there's also options of eliminating
white stars for Bishop however when they
discovered that this position is
actually nothing for white to worry
about after a3 captures captures white
can actually make a sacrifice of this e
pawn and follow that with a capture on
c6 and immediate access into the dark
squares gaining tremendous in fact we
would say even winning compensation for
the pawn so after the move Knight to c5
and the knight goes back this way
preventing that idea
y can still capture on c6 and develop an
attack on blacks dark squares here and
something you'll notice in many mainline
time modems and cons is that when black
gives up this dark squared bishop that
bishop that originally starts on f8 for
just about any piece regardless of the
compensation he gets he is always taking
a big inherent risk on his dark squares
for example if black is the castle along
here the move Bishop h6 comes in
threatening checkmate in at least
winning the exchange back and if I move
g6 is conceded we can see the white will
have compensation against these weakened
holds for the rest of the game this is
like Swiss cheese you know those
cartoons you see with the big cheese and
the you know Tom and Jerry always
fighting over it right so yeah that's
right a Tom and Jerry reference in a
chess video eat your heart out kids
after the move a6 Queen to d2
that's one mainland move order the best
approach for black can be to develop the
attack on the Queen side but rather than
trying to expose the pin simply playing
moves like castles or b5 and continue
with regular Sicilian plans trying to
attack use his minority attack for a
checkmate attack another approach for
white is simply the move Bishop to d3
and often after this move and the other
move you're about to see the plan is
very simple white wants to castle short
and and use the other plan to expose the
10 modern structure which is developing
an attack with the F and E pawns on the
Kings side usually after f4 hoping for a
5 and opening this Bishop for play on
the on the King side after the move
Bishop e3 a6 Bishop e2 this was this was
right here was a classical wasn't was a
main line for some time considered the
most popular way for both sides to play
this classical main line where black
would bring out this Bishop again we see
this pressure here on the c3 Knight
combined with frets
on the e4 and e5 squares as a way for
for black to get immediate pressure on
the center however after the move Knight
a Forex clam of iatch black is unable to
take this pawn due to a trick that
involves capturing on c6 regardless of
how black takes it we're going to we're
going to put this night on b6 and bring
our queen up to d4 applying pressure on
all different types of points when you
combine that with frets of Bishop f3
pinning the knight as well as the rook
simply coming to the D file White's
position is actually overwhelming so
after the move Knight a4 black will
typically just retreat this Bishop and
this type of play where white goes out
of its way to try to eliminate the the
light square Bishop on c8 and then
continue to put pieces on the dark
squares it is a way for white to play
again Black's plan at some point either
being to play on the Queen side with a
minority attack or try to organize the
move d5 which inherently would take away
some of the threats against this dark
squares by extending the structure back
to the beginning we talked about the
Kahlan Sicilian and in this case we play
a different move order the time on our
Sicilian can be reached via the move
word with to Knight to c6 and then e6 or
via the move order with to e6 and
followed by Knight to c6 but the con
itself can only be reached via the move
order with e6 followed by a6 as in many
types of cons black is actually not
choosing to develop as Knight to c6
instead going for a more flexible
development of the knight in many cases
it won't come to d7 so after the move a6
White has two main approaches either to
play Knight to c3 where the plan is
actually very similar to what we've
already discussed in one line of the
time on off essentially to develop
Castle kingside and try to get an attack
going with the F and E pawn advances at
some point of course trying to expose
black star squares as we know inherently
black has to be careful about ideas of
going after this Knight here as in many
cases even the win of this pawn would
not be able to fully compensate for the
potentially very very weak dark squares
once this guy gets developed so after
the move a6 Knight to c3 often Queen to
c7 Bishop d3 you can see black now go
back to Knight to c6 as he can take with
the Queen not having to take with a pawn
you'll also see the moves like b5 trying
to develop a minority attack and fee and
Ketel this Bishop and you'll also see
Knight f6
essentially in any game you will
actually see a combination of all those
things the move order particularly black
plays may be based on some sort of
theoretical idea or preparation of a
zone but all of those ideas are how
black is playing in the con against this
Knight to c3 with Bishop d3 plan and
counseling short with that for coming
the other idea for wiping Bishop III
immediately allows them of Bishop to c5
to put pressure on the knight but after
90 b3 there are two main lines for black
with the move Bishop a7 running into
usual ideas of Amarok C bind followed by
the trade of this Bishop on a7 usually
developing the Knight to c3 and in most
cases cancelling short the move Bishop
e7 doesn't seem to make as natural sense
to develop the bishop and then retreated
but black deems it in his best interest
to remove this Knight from the strong
post however here often white will
develop the point achieve for inducing
black to make a weakening move on the
kingside punishing him in a sense for
developing this bishop so early from
this square that protected the pawn and
after the Queen retreats you'll often
see the game head down play something
like this with both sides developing
their pieces and eventually white once
again trying to go back to the f4 plan
of trying to organize some sort of
effective pawn push at the right time
and black usually not worrying too much
about the dark squares in an immediate
sense but obvious having obviously
having to deal with that potential
weakness down the road okay I hope you
guys enjoyed the summary of these two
Sicilians that essentially concludes our
coverage of the open Sicilians here for
our YouTube channel via chess comm and
that's it hope you enjoyed this video
and I'll see you around on chess calm